this is going to sound strange I've been
pulled through time
you just disappeared I can't keep
looking at it because it's horrible it's
up to us to save this place you've got
about an hour
we've got about five minutes
okay come on absolutely not
streaming October 5th on Disney plus
it's go time day one
I'm excited to be back
back of the TVA
everything is stepped up again the steps
are huge get to see Tom in a suit
a lot of people are gonna like that we
introduced this whole new corner to the
MCU and these new characters
[Music]
I've been a fan of the Marvel Universe
for a long time I'm so grateful to be a
part of this amazing series rest assured
our Loki will be with our Mobius and
they will be dealing with the
consequences of this first season over
the top don't you think I thought it was
spot on season two is about Loki
understanding himself
Loki has always been a villain what we
want to explore is also low-key finding
what heroicism really looks like
we're playing God we are gods
he's found a new family there's a new
capacity to make connections what is it
that you really want I want to save my
friends he realizes that those
connections are all that matter in the
end
[Music]
he'll be here all week
[Applause]
[Music]